[Musica]
benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio del
leccio con karim usa dunque io ero
pronto ero pronto per girare il nuovo
episodio di pausa era la pausa sulla
prima puntata di dragon ball e avevo
anche finito di scriverlo mi stavo
vestendo mi stavo mettendo la giacca la
nuova cravatta ed ero pronto per girare
finché a un certo punto mi arriva una
mail di una persona che mi chiede di
collaborare è ok
ero a casa che stavo guardando tira e
molla in tv e di punto in bianco parto
parto vado alla stazione di torino porta
nuova
mi viene anche una puntina di fame mi
fermo a mangiare qualcosa e
all'improvviso mi ritrovai novara perché
come sapete il mio ufficio purtroppo non
può contenere più di una persona a meno
che tu non voglia morire soffocato e
quindi ho avuto una botta di fortuna
quando lui mi ha invitato nel suo
ufficio a novara appunto dove ci sono
molte molte molte cose abbia
aperto subito che ci stanno un pochino
di problemi tecnici legati all'audio
perché purtroppo i mezzi che ho sono
quelli che vanno bene giusto per avere
una persona davanti alla telecamera che
farmi più scemi su internet detto questo
e con un grande privilegio che vi
presento il primo ospite ufficiale
dell'aic show con karim usa giorgio
vanni
[Musica]
dove giorno perché solo perché mai
chiamato qua oggi dove stanno
ho visto la tua puntata di tanto ti
guardo spesso grazie al il cile dopo
pochissimo invece ti guardo ho visto la
tua puntata dove commenti la puntata in
cui commenti la prima dei pokémon se hai
presente ma che anzi si prepara a
chitarre bravo la piemonte
l'ho presa alta e ho visto e da
tantissimo tempo che non riguarda la
prima puntata di dragon ball tra l'altro
tra la vedo che ci aveva ancora la coda
quando ancora a parte cioè io ti devo
chiede una cosa che va detto che è un
figlio di 12 anni
sì quindi tu ne hai e allora io ne ho 35
però al contrario tour sposti il 5 anno
a 53 vado sempre pratiche complimenti la
mafia grazie hai anche tu
grazie al 68 allora io guarderei la
puntata tanto
voglio dire avviene in un periodo di
tempo misterioso in un era sconosciuta
di cui nessuno ha mai sentito parlare
della cina capreno eccolo libero in
silhouette tra l'altro ci ho provato a
fare quel calcio di monfalcone per ogni
sono incastrato
conosce io gli altri da sei anni fa come
tali io all'inizio pensavo che le stesse
fossero degli aranci eh sì perché gli
allacci del drago figuralità la vitamina
c detrarla è una storia che è stata
ispirata da una
dalla mitologia cinese lo sci genio
dello scimmiotto cioè qualsiasi e questo
mi ha sempre affascinato molto è questa
una squadra fa anche un mio amico era
già doppiata da dalla signorina a coop
ma mi sembra di sì sì sì adesso era un
meno attento si eleva sensibilmente
manuel charr manuela molto forte che
doppia anche il timbro che un
personaggio del timbro al jazz sexy
ovvero assolutamente giungesse la james
era difficile che fosse offerto da 400
integrano che fa la piccolina c'era
traccia la coda e fara pipia venuto
integrale sulla mediaset per bambini non
ho capito cosa abbia detto la portata ma
credo che abbia detto da perno è ottimo
per una sigla plata portata io e max
longhi consigli faccio tutte le sigle
abbiamo ciao max ci sta guardando
assolutamente la mira gli lo chiamo
l'ammiraglio max la giorno mi chiama il
capitano e io chiama mirò animato del
luogo di lavoro
mi ricordo che non
non vedevamo i primi cartoni questo è
stato uno dei freni che abbiamo fatto
per il quale abbiamo fatto la sigla non
vedevamo ancor non ci davano ancora dvd
perché probabilmente non si fida
alessandra valeri manera
alessandro valeri manera al una delle
sale ci dava appunto le sinossi facevamo
dei briefing nel senso delle riunioni in
cui ci spiegavano di una dinamica del
cartello
a un certo punto hanno iniziato a darci
individui del cartone animato
secondo questo punto i suoi hanno detto
ma se ci possiamo fidare
ti piace cambia bull abbia la maglia con
scritto bull ma se volete le cose forse
ricorda che apple ma mi ricorda
inevitabilmente i 200.000 cosplayer
fantastici che si vestono da bull ma è
che formano questa schiera pazzesca e
meno male che ci sono perché io
guardandomi loro labiale quando cantano
insieme a me e posso cantare
correttamente i testi per parlarne lì
sono soggetti crisi forse la mette il
primo infatti è tutti guardo il loro
rabbia le mie mi ricordo il tester 53
anni si capisce mamma mi avevi detto che
tu nonno era morto
nemmeno l'ho trovata la strada strada e
quindi io chiamo dito e cocco che sta
parla di un'arancia dell'om
beh devo dire che i nonni con i cartoni
animati
ovviamente con i bambini c'è una schiera
di i pirati e della ciurma sono
tantissimi ragazzi che con i cartoni
manga e cartoni animati li abbina lascia
il ricordo del nonno ma dentro io
purtroppo non ho avuto tanto con la
funzionali perché sono morti quando io
ero piccola e non li ho le opere non è
vissuto esatto dovere però appunto l'età
in cui abbiamo visto questo in teoria è
il periodo in cui noi stiamo dice con i
nostri nonni
se quindi anche vedere questo rapporto
tra un'altra 2 che il suo fantastico
fantastico bertone è un personaggio
fantastico sono io ti si vedeva già
drago nella prima puntata omar da
sveglio ancora a 53 anni devo decidere
se tatuarmi sul braccio destro di giuro
è un disegno che mi sa che ha fatto mio
figlio due draghi che si guardano uno
più grande e uno più di benissimo è però
devo decidere ci deve essere qualcosa
che nickname con i convincimenti ma
quali drago fare o tutt'e due
pavia si fanno quando sentii giovanile
di letti in regione ne dimentico se ti
facessi un tatuaggio faresti cadere le
donne a genere
si si non potresti approfittarne ma che
lo ha portato al pronto soccorso
ho capito che conosco un buon mezzo di
persone
è con attenzione questa cosa qua mi ha
sempre colpito del del cartone animato
giapponese che ha veramente degli
indumenti abbastanza missioni riva
quest'anno una stanza spinta abbastanza
per bebè per un cartone animato per
bambini che abbastanza scritto è infatti
prendi lupin che ager le cose e questo
mi ha sempre stupito anche perché tra
google ha un target diverso di lupin al
solo tardi nere che solitamente se non
sappiamo dove si trovano le altre sfere
del drago come facciamo trovarli sono
molto carina ma non sono uno cioè lei
che si dice sono molto carina e non solo
localmente anche se prima la foto via
delle mutande per aver la sfera però tu
sei una mappa di melo 6 porta una
fregata attivato lui che c'è la coda
dice alle 6 ma tu sera mario
è questo qua è tipo che era quest'oggi a
bari si è poi diventato che la lunghezza
ha fatto carriera e lui impara subito e
questo glielo sempre invidiato e che chi
sia accaduto tre lotti e chissà quanti
si ricordano che la prima scena d'azione
di dragone buco in moto si insegue
pullman e fai qualcosa non puoi vero
precipitate e li ha imparato ad andare
in moto ha preso la patente in 5 secondi
paradosso sta volando dargli la palla
che cercando di aiutare sempre la vede
sempre a salvare questo non è che
l'inizio del lungo avventuroso viaggio
intrapreso da burma e goku alla ricerca
delle sfere del drago riusciranno a
trovarle lo mele
lo vedrei non le va bene però c'è la
cosa che mi affascina di più negli in
alcuni non in alcuni molti anime perché
succede
nell'ambito di molte storie di di anime
è che il disegnatore il creatore da un
mix mash up tra antico e futuro si
infatti nella stessa scena puoi vedere
goku che cambierà i mezzi dinosauri e
poi bull ma che arriva con la macchina
wlan fatti con la magistrale e questa
cosa qua mi ha sempre affascinato
moltissimo mentre guardavano miei mi è
venuto in mente anche l'altro cartone di
akira toriyama per cui io e max abbiamo
fatto la sigla e l'ho cantata con
cristina d'avena con cristina dottor
slump arale ed è una delle sigle che mi
piacciono di più ma ho avuto la fortuna
di duettare con lei in tante sigle
quella sigla mi piace moltissimo e mi
piaceva mi piace tantissimo proprio il
raccontami nazione di goku in in
generale e arale nel nel mondo di golf
bella mi è piaciuta la data software
flash card noti assalito un home di
ricordi incredibile una energetica dei
ricordi salita mettere questo come
titolo del video io te lo dico beh il
ricordo principale quello più importante
così è che io e max non ci rendevamo
tanto conto che stavamo facendo una cosa
molto grande e poi questa consapevolezza
come ti dicevo prima
sì è proprio realizzata quando abbiamo
iniziato quando iniziato a fare gli
spettacoli sia vedere tutti questi
ragazzi che
e veramente sono all'inizio non riuscivo
neanche a capire questa cosa qua dal
vivo possono rivivere quei momenti in
cui appunto sentivano la sigla e
iniziava a chi guarda bene inizia il
cartone mi mi diverto dei ricordi sono
seduto sul divano con mia nonna con mio
padre
ce ne siamo resi conto dopo anche un
altro ricordo da dove prendo da doveva
di dove vado a che cosa mi ispiro a me è
sempre piaciuta la dance max del ultimi
mesi non lo faccia questi facciamo
facciamo dai andiamo avanti facciamo il
tuning stunt mettiamo una cassa in
quattro con una melodia però
assolutamente orecchiabile perché
alessandra valeri manera ciasse ci ha
sempre chiesto melody come ada agli
altri autori melodie immediate cioè che
che potessero essere memorabili tu prima
hai parlato di tools to its nelle tue
canzoni ma non sono tutte così e no mi
hanno fatto notare che per esempio la
canzone di scarafaggi e sa che scarpa
gis casca ha effettivamente tonalità
scala casi è già un bel scala allora io
abbiamo abbracciato anche jagger rock è
un rock cioè articolare con diabolik
diaboliche è stata sempre molto
apprezzata gli scarafaggi scala
e poi il reggae in alcuni c'è un sentore
di reggae in alcuni asili ed è molto
bello perché queste cose ne capisci
soltanto da un età in poi prima è solo
la sigla dei cartoni animati poi inizia
a diventare quando inizia a crescere da
spettatore una verve per canzone in cui
riesce a sentire gli strumenti il ritmo
e in genere
certo è infatti tutte le note che
facciamo il check ceo tutte le volte con
i ragazzi accenno io sono in grado è
[Musica]
riuscito ad immaginarti adesso però devo
finire una è giusto allora lì ci sono
alcuni alle strofe delle canzoni male
devo creativo o signore a tre certo
fermo né perrotta e rileggi quello che
c'è scritto e di quello più bello che
voglio sei sicuro non vuoi continuare a
fare questo è stato facile chiamo dei
playboy blade beyblade bà bà bà bà bà bà
bà bà un giallo
allora qua allora ti devo svegliare una
cosa e mentre stavamo blaze io e max
niente c'era un cane fuori
no scherzo abbiamo sempre ritenuto
importantissimo il suono il suono delle
parole
baa bà bà bà o non c'entra niente però
era come si suonava bene
spini nera nel round ovviamente perché
gira in continuazione spinning pensavo
che fosse già all'epoca lo spinning se
quello che fanno
l'acqua gene
si no le fabre e non te lo ha prima clip
boh non lo sapevi neanche tu cosa
cercare
è stata proprio una roba ci è venuto in
mente di invece di pronunciarlo in
inglese cliff pronunciavano com'è come è
scritto così almeno mi sto
arrampicandosi sul vetro della tua acqua
e mi è venuto così vediamo se serie se
riuscissi carisap di fabio taurus venosa
or die venuto bene comunque lei
pronunciate li famo fable o cinque anni
di linguistico per buttarmi via dragon
ball perché ogni sfera è la magia che
risplende in the i suoi jurmy e poi
magic to be free aspettano devo che ha
letto che nella nostra il numero dei
tubi fine world at war we have to be
fondi per farmelo dire perché se adesso
sono emozionato allora faccio schifo in
award bad bones will to be free in un
mondo che vuole veramente essere libero
in vent'anni a capirlo caccia messo 5
anni di linguistico vuoi buttarli via
così che amiamo è un'onda di energia si
sprigionerà numeriche match these
amazing che vorremmo capire
abbiamo capito che una fragilità il
senso è che non si può come si dice non
si può
allora io l'ho capito no bari che mac
business in cat nessuno puoi sbagliare e
meciar e questa fantastica presa qui
oppure questa fantastica cattura igiene
sono duri sono la stessa frase da due
che si riversi su internet perché fars
no è boorstin through the clouds c'è che
esplode tra tra le tra le nuvole
fantastico e poi fai tin underground
cioè combatte sul terreno sul nell'ombra
resterà il volto play gestendo way to
acidi offendi per acquistare la tua same
per arrivare al tuo successo perché per
noi era strizzi ei tre volte i volti way
e strizzi way perché non sapevamo
assolutamente io io all'inizio volevo
striscia away ma poi non me l'hanno
fermato è stata una tortura per ragazzi
vi voglio ricordare una cosa che a me a
me ha nulla di chè match di mesi in cash
e questa è la storia di come ho
conosciuto giorgio vanni io sono
veramente onorato ed è stato magnifico
poter collaborare con lui
grazie mille e ci vediamo ad un prossimo
episodio
cari non lo sai vero presso lo scoprirai
e poi tutti firmerà
[Musica]